what is it about this uh Bonnie Raitt
song why are you doing this cover out of
all the covers you guys could possibly
do I think um I I just wanted to play
the granddaddy song of them all like the
most beautiful tormented uh but still
like you don't know what you want your
heart to feel when you hear this because
it's so beautiful musically but it's
such a painful message to hear that um
you can't make somebody love you and I
just don't know if there will ever be a
song that's written like this I think
this song took the slot and
um
it's
that's just one it's just a song that I
wish that I wrote quite honestly and as
you say it is the most frustrating
experience
I Can't Make You Love Me and the idea of
her standing before a guy saying it is
pretty powerful stuff and yes and I hope
I can do I I won't do it as well as her
but I'll sure try him as hell
foreign
foreign
turn down the bed
turn down these voices
inside my head
lay down with me
tell me no lies
just hold me close I don't pay tonight
don't patronize
is me
cause I can't make you love me if you
don't
you can make your heart feel
something it would
here in the dark and these Final hours
[Music]
[Music]
I Can't Make You Love Me
if you don't
[Music]
I close my eyes
and I won't see
the love you don't feel
when you're holding me
morning will come
I'll do what's right
give me till then so give up this fight
and I will get
fired
cause I can't make you love me if you
don't
you can make your heart feel something
in these Final hours
[Music]
[Music]
if you don't
[Music]
fantastic